recently streamer ice poseidon has been
accused of making 300 000 from a crypto
rug pool scam at the expense of
investors some of whom were his fans now
he's explaining his side of the story
why he believes it's not a scam and why
he won't be giving any of the money back
all right before we dive into this one
have a look below the video and make
sure you subscribe to the score esports
if you are then you can get our videos
more easily that will make you happy
which will make us happy which will make
you happy you get the idea subscribe ice
poseidon has been a fairly big streamer
now for over five years and is mostly
known for his raw and often chaotic
streams he made headlines back in 2017
when he was swatted on stream after a
viewer called in a bomb hoax as ice
poseidon was boarding a plane in phoenix
i might be on terminal 5 i don't know
what i don't know where i am i'm just on
53a as my that's my gate
and i'm not sure telling you guys that
is a good idea but i what can you
possibly do right passengers on that
american airlines flight from los
angeles say that after they landed here
the pilot simply told them our gates not
ready he parked and said everyone put
your shades down well when someone
peeked out of the shade this is what
they saw police surrounding the plane
and then police ended up boarding that
plane passengers say that two people
were removed a man and a woman he was
running around with a gopro
type thing and a big
large camera and passengers say after
police took those two off the plane the
plane made its way to the gate
everything else from there
went as normal
he was then permanently suspended on
twitch and has been streaming on youtube
ever since it's safe to say that after
bans scandals and run-ins with the law
ice poseidon has fostered a bit of a
reputation over the years that's why
some people were suspicious when in july
2021 he announced he was creating his
own crypto coin cx coin named after his
now disbanded streaming group the
announcement for this didn't go too
smoothly because footage was circulating
online a vice president bragging about
pulling a literal rug pull scam that is
getting others to buy into a coin and
inflate its value before cashing out
leaving the currency practically
worthless also known as a pump and dump
scam because dude if i see it if i see a
million dollars i'm selling i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm not gonna be like i'll hold
for you guys bro i see a million dollars
in my portfolio i'm out you're telling
me i could create
a cx coin and then people could buy it
because i could say that the community
is super strong and then i could sell it
in 10 seconds and make 10 million
dollars and this all came right around
the time that members of faze clown were
suspended for their roles in the save
the kids crypto scam which we reported
on at the time it turned out that this
kid's coin as it's referred to as was
potentially one giant scam that could be
highly illegal it was certainly sketchy
enough that faze k got fired from the
org while his brother jarvis and another
member nikan were suspended over their
involvement with the project a few
months later when phase k puts out an
explanation video youtube investigator
coffeezilla did a great job of breaking
down what happened in recent years
coffeezilla has begun to establish
himself as a real thorn in the side of
shady influences his investigations have
looked into the likes of business guru
tai lopez gun toting playboy dan
bilzerian and the scam accusations
surrounding business mogul dan lok but
his investigations in to save the kids
firmly place coffee zilla as the go-to
guy when it comes to influencer crypto
scams and it was for this reason that
ice poseidon actually reached out to him
to offer evidence that cx coin wasn't a
scam such as the details of his crypto
wallet even ice beside knew that when it
comes to influences and crypto they're
never too far from the watchful eye of
coffeezilla so with my free time i
joined the cx coin telegram and started
tracing back the wallets that ice
poseidon had given me so transparently
and pretty soon i found out that well he
gave me the wrong crypto wallets whoops
he gave me the dx sale wallet instead of
his personal wallet which didn't tell me
anything for example one of those things
he didn't tell me was the fact that he
took out two hundred thousand dollars
from the liquidity pool at the very
beginning which is directly at odds with
what ice poseidon told me himself when i
asked in fact what coffeezilla found was
that ice poseidon had pulled three
hundred thousand dollars from the
liquidity pool the shared pot of money
that investors buy into and which allows
them to trade one asset for another
it looks like the coin got rugged
you know anything about that
i mean yeah i mean not rugged but uh i
mean
well someone pulled all the liquidity
out that's a that's a rub right
that would be a rug yes uh but
there is still liquidity in there
what like a yeah i mean the majority got
ripped out right what
40k got left and 300k got ripped out or
something like that
yeah i mean
that is exactly what happened ice
poseidon's main defense seemed to be
that there was still some money left in
the liquidity pool and that the other
money that was withdrawn was done so
because of an impending crypto market
crash but as the call went on it seemed
like ice poseidon wasn't really
defending himself at all you taught
everybody it wasn't a scam you had these
videos
where you said you were joking where you
said you'd scam people as soon as you
thought the money was going to be
basically take it away you were going to
rip it out from under everybody uh and
then you i asked you about it you said
it's a you were joking
it doesn't seem like a joke anymore it
seems like you scammed your fans
uh no not a not a scam um you don't
think we're drawing 300k is is a scam
like
at the time the project needs it the
most when ice poseidon said that the
coin was inactive he meant that he was
no longer giving any updates for it that
he wasn't doing any marketing for it he
had essentially let go of the whole
thing in the interview with coffee zilla
he said that the reason for this was due
to the bad publicity the coin received
when the video of him talking about
doing a pump and dump scheme first
circulated online which he maintains was
a joke but carvezilla was quick to point
to a ledger post on the coins telegram
of him telling people that this project
was long term when he was pressed on why
he pulled the plug on the whole thing
and didn't tell people to withdraw their
own money beforehand ice beside and deny
that that's what happened because there
is still some money left in the
liquidity and also that quite simply the
investors should have known better than
to leave their money there so they were
dumb to give you the benefit of the
doubt uh your your fans were not smart
to give you the benefit of the doubt on
this project that you told them you were
long term on
uh no that's not what i'm saying
i'm saying that if something's inactive
for months if you have money in there
that you don't want to lose
why are you like why keep it in there
it's inactive it's it's you know what i
mean you're the one saying people should
not be looking for short-term gains they
should be looking at it and like a
long-term project right
yeah
and normally with these kinds of things
the accused can be quite evasive when it
comes to numbers and figures but whether
it's because of the transparent nature
of cryptocurrency or belief of his
innocence i president talk quite frankly
about how much money he'd taken from all
of this after 45 went to developers he
said that his 55 netted him around 300
000
on february 1st ice poseidon shared a
twit longer which he said was his one
and only response on the subject it's
filled with a lot of crypto terminology
which he admits might be hard to grasp
if you're a noob to crypto but maintains
that he did not steal or scam anyone of
course this is something coffee zilla
objected to once again in a final reply
video so i was trying to understand what
he was saying and you know what i
realized you can translate all of the
jargon all of everything he says into
basically one sentence over and over
repeated which is i'm keeping the money
like take this for example it was
completely unnecessary to have 400
thousand dollars in the lp 264 in the lp
150 k in the buyback function and the
money was at risk at getting the value
due to the crypto markets dropping so
you could try to understand that why
it's unnecessary for his fans to have
four hundred thousand dollars why they
don't need it or you could just replace
it with i'm keeping the money it just
reads so much better that way look the
whole thing actually reads better i'm
keeping the money i'm keeping the money
i'm keeping the money i'm keeping the
money and of course i highly recommend
coffeezilla's videos on this if you want
to hear their conversation in full and
his analysis on the whole thing crypto
rogue pool scams are growing year on
year right now a report by the financial
post found that roguepool scams made
over 2.8 billion dollars in 2021 alone
up 81 on the previous year it's been a
year that seen massive scams such as the
squid game rogue pool which used to hit
netflix show's name to pull in investors
before cleaning them out of some 3.3
million dollars in funds as this trend
continues the calls for legislation grow
louder naturally government legislation
is pretty much the antithesis of what
cryptocurrency is all about unregulated
decentralized currencies that are
beholden to no one a lot of the reason
these things happen is because the
perpetrators are difficult to trace
they're nameless faceless figures that
are protected by the anonymity of the
blockchain crypto literacy is on the
rise and the hope at least is that as
people become more knowledgeable about
this world they'll be less susceptible
to scams such as the crypto rogue pool
you